السلام عليكم ورحمه الله ادلت الصحافه
الاسرائيليه بدلوها هي الاخرى في ملف
المعلومات التي يقال ان الرئيس الامريكي
دونالد ترامب افشاه في لقاء جمعه بوزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرغي لافروف معلومات
تتعلق بجاسوس بارز زرع بين صفوف تنظيم
الدوله قالت وسائل اعلام امريكيه انه
اسرائيلي بينما اشارت القناه الاسرائيليه
الثانيه الى ان ما رشح عنه يشير الى مصادر
معلومات يدكها الاردن بين صفوف التنظيم
وفي انتظار ان تتضح الصوره بالكامل حول
الجاسوس المثير للجدل وتفاصيل ارشاء
المعلومات المتعلقه به يبدو ان المخوف
تصاعدت لدى حلفاء امريكا بخصوص التنسيق
الامني مع البيت الابيض فكثير من تلك
الدول الحليفه ومنها اسرائيل باتت تطرح
السؤال التالي ما الذي يجب ان يقال وما
الذي يجب الا يقال لترامب
مستقبلا زميل فتحي اسماعيل ومزيد من
التفاصيل في التقرير التي
لا محاولات البيت الابيض المحمومه ولا
تغريدات الرئيس الامريكي نفسه افلحت في
تطويق ما بات يعرف بفضيحه افشاء دونالد
ترامب اسرارا بالغه السريه الى وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرغي لافروف خلال
لقائهما في واشنطن يوم الحادي عشر من
الشهر الحالي وفق صحيفه الواشنطن بوست فان
ترامب ابلغ لافروف يومها بتفاصيل مخطط
لتنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه لتفجير احدى
الطائرات باستخدام حواسيب محموله وهي
معلومات تضاربت الروايات بشان مصدرها
فبينما قالت وسائل اعلام امريكيه ان
اسرائيل استقتها عبر جاسوس لها داخل قياده
التنظيم تحدثت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه عن
ان الاردن هو مصدر تلك المعلومات الحساسه
وان كشفها سيهدد المصادر الاستخباريه التي
تعتمد عليها عمان داخل تنظيم الدوله
الازمه تتس وتفاعل اعلاميا وسياسيا وهي في
الوسط الاستخباراتي بدت صفحه قويه لا
لقيمه المعلومات المسربه فحسب وانما ايضا
لتاثيرات المستقبليه المحتمله على تعاون
الاجهزه الامريكيه مع نظيراتها الصديقه
والحليف التي قد تتردد او تمتنع عن تقاسم
اي اسرار معها خشيه وصولها الى الطرف
الخطا كما فعل ترامب في اسرائيل حيث يحاول
الرسميون التكتم على فضيحه التسريبات
اسبوعا قبل زياره ترامب حفل الاعلام
الاسرائيلي بها ونقل عن دانيا توم الرئيس
السابق للموساد قوله ان اسرائيل ستفكر الف
مره قبل ان تزود الامريكيين باي معلومات
في المستقبل يقول خبراء قانون امريكيون ان
تقديم معلومات حساسه لبلد عدو يمكن ان
يشكل جنحه كبرى وخرقا للقسم الرئاسي الذي
يتعهد بالحفظ
على مصالح البلاد وحمايتها والامر يبدو
مرجحا اكثر عندما يتعلق بروسيا المتهمه
اصلا بالتدخل في الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي
اوصلت ترامب الى البيت الابيض حتى الان
يحاجج ترامب بحقه المطلق في تبادل
المعلومات الاستخباريه مع الدول الاخرى
ويبدي الجمهوريون تماسكا في الكونجرس لكن
مصطلح عزل الرئيس اصبح متداولا في الذهن
الامريكي على الاقل بصيغه النفي او
الاستبعاد
نناقش بشكل اوسع هذا الموضوع مع ضيفين من
بوستون مع جلين كارل الضابط السابق في
وكاله المخابرات الامريكيه المركزيه ومؤلف
كتاب المحقق الذي يتحدث عن تنظيم القاعده
ومع ضيفنا من تل ابيب اسرائيل هاريل
الكاتب في صحيفه ريتس
الاسرائيليه سيد جلين كارل مع هذه
التقارير الاعلاميه الاسرائيليه
بخصوص هويه الجاسوس وما ما تم تسريبه من
الصحافه الامريكيه هل يمكن
القول باننا الان ربما اقتربنا اكثر من
الحقيقه حول تسريبات
ترامب فيما
يتعلق بالبيت
الابيض و المكتب البيضاوي وتمريره معلومات
الى روس نعرف بشكل جيد باعتقادي ان ما هي
الحقائق هنالك العديد من التقارير التي
اذا ما تم جمعها يبدو انها تبدو ترسم صوره
واضحه عن المعلومات التي كشفها اسم
المدينه نوع التهديدات والاطر الزمنيه كل
هذه المعلومات المفيده
للاستخبارات المناظره وايضا بالنسبه لشخص
معادي كروس بامكانه ان ربما ان يح
نقاط اهتمامنا ما الذي نعرفه وكيف سنعرف
لذلك هي معلومات مهمه للغايه سيد
اسرائيل الصحافه الاسرائيليه تحدثت بان
اسرائيل ربما قد تبحث في مراجعه طريقه او
اسلوب واليه تنسيق وتبادل المعلومات
والاسرار الاستخباراتيه مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الى اي حد
ربما قد يبدو مبالغا فيه هذا الحديث
الاعلامي
بدايه اعتقد انها تم المبالغه بشكل كبير
في هذا الامر عاده
انا لا افهم الرئيس ترامب هو
يتصرف
بطريقه لا يفهمها العديد من الاشخاص
وباختصار هو لا يتصرف
كرئيس كرئيس يمثل اعظم قوه في العالم مع
ذلك عندما يتعلق الامر بتسريب مثل هذه
المعلومات اعتقد انني اوافق معه هو لديه
الحق والامتياز على انه القائد الاعلى
للقوات
المسلحه لاطلاع الاخر او نظرائه على
المعلومات لكن مع ذلك يجب عليك ان تطلب
الاذن منم منحك المعلومات وانا لست متاكدا
من انه طلب الاذن انا اعرف ان رئيس
الاستخبارات العسكريه جنرال هلاب موجود في
واشنطن الان من الواضح
انه حسب ترتيبات سابقه لكن اعتقد انه
سيناقش هذا الامر
وربما قنوات التواصل من الان وصاعدا من
اسرائيل الى الولايات المتحده ستكون اكثر
تنظ
وربما اكثر حذرا في مساله ايصال المعلومات
ربما
الرئيس
سيتم اعطاه ايجازا للمعلومات حول كيفيه
ايصال المعلومات ولمن يعطيها ولمن لا
يعطيها هو ما يزال مبتدئ في هذا المجال
ليس لديه اي خبره
في المعلومات السريه العالميه وانا اعتقد
انه لم يقصد اي اذى لكن لكن السؤال المهم
والاكيد في حقيقه الامر
كيف بان اقرب الحلفاء اليوم هم روسيا
للولايات المتحده الكثير من المراقبين
السياسيين والخبراء الاستخبارات لا يفهمون
هذا الامر هنالك شيء غامض جدا في العلاقه
بين الرئيس ترامب وبين الرئيس بوتين حقيقه
ان الرئيس بوتين اتى ودافع عن الرئيس
ترامب ايضا يثير الكثير من الاسئله ما نوع
العلاقه
التي
تلاحظ وجودها بين ليس فقط الولايات
المتحده وروسيا لكن بين قاده الدولتين سيد
جين كارن سيدين كارن يعني نقص حديثنا عن
عن المعلومات التي كشفتها قناه بي س نيوز
عن ما ما نقلته عن بعض المسؤولين السابقين
في الاداره الامريكيه بان الجاسوس المعني
بالامر هو جاسوس اسرائيلي
لتنظيم الدوله وبان حياته باتت مهدده الى
اي حد تتفق او تختلف مع هذه صحه هذه
الانباء وهل يمكن ان تصل يصل التعامل مع
الاداره الامريكيه وجهاز الاستخبارات
الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه طبعا في ترامب
وجهاز الاستخبارات الذي تربطه علاقات
متوتره مع الرئيس لحد الكشف عن معلومات في
غايه الاهميه وغايه السريه كهذه ويكشفها
ترامب لضيفه الروسي هل تعتقد بان هذا
وارد ان هذا ممكن البيت الابيض نفسه قد
اعترف انه قد حدث هذا الامر وكما وصفته
وسائل الاعلام ان القضيه الانكار وبعد ذلك
عدم الانكار
خلال عذرا عذرا سيدين كارل انا اتحدث هنا
عن المعلومه الدقيقه عن هويه الجاسوس الذي
يزعم بانه مدسوس في في تنظيم الدوله وذكر
الهويه وهو انه
اسرائيلي بينما اسرائيل
تنفي
انا امل ان اسرائيل تقوم بنكران هذا الامر
يجب ان لا تقدم اي معلومات حول كيفيه
حصولها على المعلومات وما هي المعلومات
ومن الذي يحصل عليها لذلك هذا هو امر
طبيعي ومن المناسب لاسرائيل ان تقوم بهذا
الامر هل بامكان اسرائيل ان يكون لها مصدر
المعلومات مثل هذا نعم معظم الول التي
لديها اهتمام او مصالح او تتاثر بتنظيم
الدوله ستحاول القيام بذلك
الامر ليس يمثل لا يمثل لي اي شك على
الاطلاق سيد
هاريل القناه الاسرائيليه الثانيه قالت
بان ما رشح عن الجاسوس يشير الى مصادر
معلومات يملكها الاردن بين صفوف التنظيم
لماذا تريد اسرائيل الزجه بالاردن في
الموضوع ولماذا ترمي هذه الكره الساخنه في
الملعب
الاردني يجب علي ان اقول انه في اسرائيل
فان المصادر
الاستخباريه لا تقلق بشكل كبير حول
التسريبات كما هو الحال في الولايات
المتحده في الولايات
المتحده لست متاكدا في حقيقه الامر من ان
وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه مهتمه بشكل كبير حول مساله
التسريبات الامنيه او تعريض حياه جاسوس
يعمل او منخرط في تنظيم الدوله هم مهتمون
بالحمله ضد الرئيس ترامب كل شيء يقوم به
فانه الع تقف ضده لا نعرف حقيقه الامر
نسبه او خطوره التسريبات او النتائج
الخطيره المترتبه من هذه
التسريبات
حقيقه ان امريكا وروسيا واسرائيل والاردن
وقوى اخرى لديها مصادر للمعلومات
الاستخباريه مزروعه في تنظيم الدوله امر
واضح ومفهوم كل جهات استخباراتي يريد ان
يعرف ما يحدث داخل تنظيم
الدوله ان تنظيم الدوله دائما ينظر ايضا
ويبحث ايضا عن جواسيس لذلك
اعتقدوا اننا لسنا متاكدين تماما من ان
هذا الجاسوس او العميل الخاص في خطر حقيقي
لكن الم
الحالي غريب للغايه وانا اعتقد ان معظمنا
لا يفهم تماما ما الذي حدث فعلا انا احاول
ان اتحدث مع مصادر المعلومات الموجوده لدي
في اسرائيل ولحد الان فهمت انهم ليسوا
قلقين حقا كمستوى مستوى الاعلام الامريكي
وربما ان ايضا مستوى قلق الجهاز
الاستخباراتي
هناك
كارل على ذكر القلق وايضا على ذكر
التداعيات المحتمله لمثل هذه التسريبات
برايك ما حجم الضرار الذي سيلحق الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في اطار علاقاتها مع
حلفائها في اطار تنسيقها وتبادلها
للمعلومات الاستخباراتيه والى اي حد قد
يؤثر هذا فعلا على هذا التنسيق و والى اي
مستوى قد يصل
التاثير و
في حقيقه الامر سنعرف هذا الامر بمرور
الوقت لكن كقانون او كقاعده عامه اذا ما
كان هنالك اذا ما اخذنا اسوا سيناريوهات
ونحاول ان نتفاعل مع هذا الامر بالنسبه
لاجهزه الاستخبارات نعرف ان هنالك شيء خطا
قد حصل هنالك قانون الدوله الثالثه ما
نسميه في الاستخبارات اذا تم توفير
معلومات من جهه ثالثه لا يمكن تقاسمها مع
دوله ثالثه بدون موافقه الدوله الاولى هذا
اتفاق جدي ومهم بين الاجهزه الاستخبارات
العالميه وعندما
يتم عدم احترام هذه هذا الاتفاق فان
النتائج والعواقب خطيره في هذه الحادثه قد
لا يكون هنالك اي عواقب او قد يكون لكن
كمبدا عام عندما يكون هنالك خرق من هذا
الامر ومن يتم اخذه بنظر الاعتبار في
اجهزه
الاستخبارات الامريكيه مثلا انا في
الميدان عندما ارتكب خطا مثل هذا بهذه
الطبيعه سيتم استدعائي وربما سيكون هنالك
اضرار كبيره لذلك بالنسبه للامريكيين هذا
الامر في غايه الاهميه ومشكله كبيره وبتال
وبالتالي سيد جرين كارل في حال انكشفت
حقيقه هذه التسريبات بشكل الكامل وثبتت
على ترامب مسؤوليه ما هل او كيف سينعكس
ذلك على مستقبله السياسي كرئيس للولايات
المتحده هذا هذه نقطه مهمه ارغب بالتحدث
عنها هنالك الكثير من جهود للدفاع عن
دونالد ترامب في الولايات المتحده من قبل
الجمهوريين ومن قبل حلفائه يقولون ان
الرئيس مرخص لقول ما يقوله ومشاركه
بالمعلومات التي
يرغبها المنطق يقول نعم قد يكون هذا الامر
صحيحا لكن في الواقع هو ليس كذلك الرئيس
لا ليس لديه يد مطلقه في كل الامور هو
مقيد بمسؤولياته بالاضافه الى حقوقه ايضا
فعليه واجبات اذا ما اراد ان يكشف معلومات
لاي سبب يجب ان يقوم به ما قام به الرئيس
بوش مثلا والذي قال يقول انني اريد ان
اطلع هذه المعلومات واشاركها وبعد ذلك
يسمع من جهازه استخباراته كيف بامكانه ان
يقوم بذلك بدون اي مخاطر لكن ان يقوم بذلك
في سبيل حديث
عابر هذا الامر ببساطه لا يتم القيام به
ولديه عواقب والرئيس لا يملك هذا الحق
شكرا لك سيد جلين كار الضابط السابق في
وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه ومؤلف
كتاب المحقق الذي يتحدث عن تنظيم القاعده
من بوستون كما نشكر من ضيفنا ضيفنا من
تلبيب اسرائيل هاريل الكاتب في صحيفه ارس
الاسرائيليه